hello everyone and welcome to a game
that is a complete
roller coaster it's from day two of the
uh noon chess classic magnus cross and
versus hikaru nakamura as you know
yesterday magnus won the match he won
two games he car won
uh none two games were drawn and now
hikaru has to bounce back he has to win
the match by at least a two-point margin
to force tie breaks
and to maybe uh maybe win this finals
but this game it's uh already i think
this is definitely the craziest game of
all the games in the finals so far
so let's check it out uh he car with the
white pieces and it's
uh you know it's it's like i said a real
roller coaster i'm going to ask you to
pause the videos at least
three times maybe more so if you're not
ready for that you know yeah get ready
for that so without further ado
let's check it out and let's uh you know
switch from the 4k
camera to a normal view uh and uh he car
with the white pieces opens with d4
sorry about that i'll just fix that uh
we have knight to f6 by magnus
c4 we have e6 knight to c3 and now
magnus goes for the nimzo indian defense
we have bishop to b4
uh queen to c2 going for the classical
variation and
now striking in the center with d5 going
for the noah variation
c captures e captures and now bishop to
g5 so
all very standard stuff here we have h6
bishop to h4
and now again striking in the center
with c5
that we have d captures on c5 and now a
normal way to continue this
uh or rather not a normal way but the
most usual way is g5 bishop g3 and
knight e4
now putting more pressure on the c3
knight but here for this game
magnus goes bishop to e6 and it's not a
new move but it is a very rare one
we have e3 preparing to develop the
light square bishop
castles by black and now knight to f3 we
have knight beat the d7
and now comes knight to d4 a bit
more usual is bishop to e2 it's a kind
of a more principled idea not playing
with the same piece twice in the opening
but he car knows what he's doing we have
knight to d4
now going after this bishop on e6 and
magnus ghost
bishop captures on c5 here he had to
decide whether to capture with the nitro
with the bishop and he spent some four
minutes on this idea
uh which is a lot as these are 15 minute
games
so he played bishop captures on c5 not
worrying about knight captures on e6 and
he car just went bishop to d3 instantly
saying i prepared for this you know
i'm more than ready so magnus eliminates
the knight in the center
gives up the bishop pair we have e
captures and now queen to b6 putting
pressure on the d4 pawn
but hikaru just plays queen to d2 uh
indirectly defending the pawn and i know
none of you were actually considering
grabbing this because if you grab it
bishop h7 check
wins the queen so of course uh he didn't
go for that we have knight to e for now
attacking hikaru's queen and now bishop
captures an e4 we have d
captures and now d5 grabbing more space
in the center
now after the bishop moves we're going
to go after the spawn so
bishop f5 defending the pawn not
allowing the capture and only now hikaru
castles
we have queen the g6 shifting the queen
over to the
king side and now you do have some ideas
here maybe the bishop can threaten check
maybe you can bring your knight into the
game somehow to threaten some other
ideas
but all in all uh you know if white is
able to survive that it's a white who
has a pass deep on and that pawn is very
very
close to queening so here hikaru pushes
it to d6
and now comes knight to e5 the
premature bishop h3 doesn't really do
anything you just block with bishop to
g3 and now this bishop is just you know
doing nothing here so you'd have to
bring it back so magnus brings the
knight into the game and this is now a
very nice move
and now already uh threatening knight to
f3 check which would win
white's queen uh the g pawn is pinned
so bishop to g3 this is strongest hikaru
takes care of everything
and now rook after e8 and already here
hikaru is still above
the 15 minute mark which is a lot since
you start with 15 minutes and magnus is
already down to six minutes
maybe six and a half minutes so here
hikaru has a lot of options here he can
bring the rooks into the game rook c1
rook d1
uh the other rook can come into the game
you can centralize the queen maybe put
additional pressure to the knight
but he goes for knight to b5 again a
very nice idea threatening knight to c7
to win one of the rooks so magnus goes
to rook a to d8
and now comes queen to c3 with
a double attack on this sorry about the
arrows uh with the double attack on the
knight on e5
and now while uh magnus could go uh you
know
forward with knight to d3 he he decides
to go back and keep
everything safe so knight to c6 as you
all know strongest move is always with
the knight back most of the time so why
not
knights the c7 by hikaru attacking the
rook here and now
rook to f8 you don't really have any
other squares for this rook so rook to
f8 is a must
and now rook 8 to d1 you could also play
rocket to c1 but hikaru has an idea of
what
he wants to do with the other rook so
rocket to d1 and now
h5 which makes sense because uh
well you want to push this pawn all the
way at some point but for the moment the
h4 square is defended by this bishop so
it's not really an issue although you
could play h4
and eliminate all of black's counter
play on the queen side forever hikaru
says nope
uh there's no need to rush that he goes
queen to c5
and now he already has some plans of
maybe rook d5 put pressure on the bishop
if the bishop moves their pressure on
the h pawn
so what do you do here uh first rook to
d7
you do not want to allow this pawn to be
pushed so rook to d7
blocking this and now b4 now hikar wants
to dislodge the knight from c6 and
magnus prevents this we have a6 and now
a4
again you could have uh some other moves
the
rook can come to d5 like we said uh the
knight can come to d5 then later on you
can play knight d7 check
could be very strong but hikaru not in a
rush he starts uh you know
just pushing those queen side pawns and
now uh comes a move that was uh well
sort of characterized in the live
coverage as clear desperation from
magnus carlsen and he pushes
e3 here because it's not easy to find
the move uh
there there really are no great moves
here so he he plays e3 it's a positional
pawn sacrifice it frees the e4 square
from
for the bishop and then maybe you can do
some threats with h4 so it makes sense
in a position like this
to make such a move but we'll see what
happens so if you capture with the queen
then
you give up the b4 pawn so car just
captures with the pawn
he says nope this is not a problem and
now bishop to e4 now h4 is the threat
because if the bishop moves queen g2
will be checkmate
and situation on the clock is eight
minutes for hikaru uh and
four minutes for magnus so here we have
rook to d2
just defending that pawn uh here hikaru
had a bit of a
you know maybe uh maybe a more active
move but it's uh you know
uh crazy to look for such things in a
rapid game i'm just gonna show it
because it's super
uh fun knight to d5 and now the point is
if h4 if the bishop moves now you're
going to get checkmated now the problem
is 97 check forking the king and the
queen
so you have to capture the knight now
pawn captures threatening to capture
this guy with
check now rookie 8 and now rook captures
on d7 and finally after h
captures on g3 now we're gonna play h4
and you have this position where
white is of course winning but it's uh
it's an ugly position to
analyze uh you know from the uh set
position so after bishop to e4 we have
rook to d2 hikaru
keeps it safe he can really go all out
he
is very much behind in the match so here
uh magnus goes king to h7 and it's a
it's a move you don't really want to
make but it's hard to find a better one
a better one might be something like b6
upon sacrifice to maybe start activating
your pieces queen captures and rook b8
uh that's one idea but okay magnus went
for queen
king to h7 and now again hikaru could go
something like knight to d5 like we said
this is always an idea but he first
starts with b5 it makes sense let's
dislodge this knight
and then we're gonna go for such ideas
so we have captures captures
knight to d8 and only now knight to d5
so what can magnus do here
uh he starts by activating the knight
the king is no longer on g8 so you don't
really have to worry about knight e7
check but 97 is an ugly move when it
comes whenever it comes
and hikaru goes for queen to c4 now the
there's pressure on this bishop here
and uh you always have to keep an eye uh
ideas like uh
well okay not now uh as this knight is
on e6 but ideas like rook to d for rook
therefore could really put a lot of
pressure
along the fourth rank so here we have h
for by magnus now really going
all out here and now hikaru has one very
very
excellent move so this is only the first
pause the video moment so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning idea for hikaru while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting this
uh well a move with the knight forward
and for those of you if you just want to
enjoy the show it's
knight the e7 and this is extremely
powerful here
uh now the problem is the queen is under
attack you have to move the queen you
don't really have the option of
capturing here so queen to g4 by magnus
and
now comes bishop e5 by hikaru and
now you'll see that black is really in a
lot of trouble a more
straightforward way was bishop to f4
because it immediately comes with a
threat and after bishop to g6 we have
this h3 idea
now the queen has to move and after the
queen moves now for example rook d5 we
further harass the queen
and if something like f5 then e4 and you
know black's position is simply
unbearable
but okay like i said this is a rapid
game bishop the e5 was played by hikaru
and now comes knight to g5 so again uh
very tricky position
magnus with a lot of threats here and
it's not easy to find the move for
hikaru here
magnus is down to one minute on the
clock hikaru almost three minutes on the
clock here
and hikaru has to find rook to f4 if
hikaru finds rook to f4
then it's just game over magnus you
don't really gain anything by knight to
h3 check
just king h1 and after knight captures
on f4 we're just gonna play
queen that captures an e4 with check and
now we win material
if f5 we're just gonna capture here and
now white has just too much material for
example captures captures and this is
not completely winning for hikaru
however uh this is chess and in chess
great things always happen he covered
did not play rook to f4
rather he played bishop to f4 and now
it's actually magnus who's completely
winning
and now i think this is the nicest move
of the entire game so feel free to pause
the video and
find this brilliant winning idea for
magnus while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on
not doing again anything weird and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
rook captures on d6 and now look at
white's position all of a sudden
white doesn't really have any threats
and uh you know his pieces are hanging
what about the rook here on d1 uh that
rook is defending this
if this rook moves then we're just gonna
get checkmate for example if captures
then this is checkmate
and even if you don't capture this
there's really no good move here for
example if
bishop captures this is even worse well
not even worse as that one ends in
checkmate
but here you lose the queen the queen on
c4 is undefended
and now we just play knight h3 check
there is no move here you can't go to f2
king h1 is the only move
and now the king is on a light square
and that's exactly where we want him
bishop captures with czech rook captures
and now we pick up the queen queen
captures on c4
and now black is completely winning but
again this is chess
and magnus did not find rook captures on
d6 he was under a minute
and of course i mean uh who who who
finds such a move
uh he played knights the h3 check right
away
we have king to h1 and now he strikes
with
f5 this is the correct way to play now
everything seems to be in order and the
both of them are now under a minute so
this is now bullet chess and the
position is just
amazing so here hikaru immediately dives
in with queen to e6 this is best
attacking the undefended rook on d7
and magnus goes for knight captures on
f4 now with
a triple attack here on the g2 pawn
hikaru
eliminates it with the rook attacking
the queen and now
magnus tries sacrificing the queen he
plays rook the a8
saying all right if you capture my queen
then i'm just going to deliver rook to
a1 check and you only have one
rook d1 rook captures will be checkmate
hikaru of course not interested in that
he finds a
very nice defensive idea king the g1
although there was a nicer one queen e5
guards the a1 square and you know white
keeps
all of his ideas alive uh not much for
for magnus to do here
but okay uh king to g1 was played and
now comes
uh rook the a1 check rook the f1
at least magnus eliminates one of the
attackers rook captures king captures
and now
rook to d8 as the rook was still hanging
we have
h3 chasing back carlson's queen queen to
g5
and now d7 and now this pawn is just a
monster here and the magnus
will have a terrible time defending
against this so
you don't really have an option this
queen and knight are guarding all of
these squares i mean there's really not
nowhere for you to move the rook can
never move you just uh sorry about that
you just promote this pawn to a queen
that's game over and
what can magnus do magnus can hope that
he karu blunder so
magnus plays queen captures on e3 uh
attacks the rook now here but he leaves
the g6
square undefended so the queen to g6
check was played
king the h8 and now queen the queen to
e8 is the possibility of course about
hikaru plays the more precise line
uh queen h5 check now king the g8
uh of course is impossible because the
knight covers this and now
queen to h6 now comes queen e8 to check
uh and now of course uh the queen cannot
be captured if
the queen is captured and we just bring
a queen into the game and after the king
moves this is just checkmate
so after queen t8 check king h7 and
now comes queen captures and d8 that's
the idea
uh and now uh the rook of course cannot
be captured if the rook is captured it's
just uh well it's actually a fourth
check made in 10 but that doesn't really
matter because
black just loses the queen very quickly
king h6 we're gonna deliver this check
then king g5 then we're gonna sorry
uh capture this guy here and after queen
f4 queen h6 check we'll pick up the
queen on d2
and very quickly will checkmate the
black king
so instead after queen captures on v8
magnus tries
one last idea bishop captures and g2 and
it's a very good idea because if hikaru
captures
then we captured the rook with check and
now you're not going to be able to
uh you know survive all of the checks
for example queen d3 queen
king f4 queen g3 check king captures
queen f2 check and now you will be able
to check
the white king to infinity hopefully uh
so hikaru of course
not interested in that after this check
hikaru plays king to
e2 now magnus tries it one more time he
plays
bishop to f1 check and now even though
this one can be captured because this
does not come with check hikaru just
plays the com king to d1
and it was in this position on move 49
that magnus carlsen resigned in the game
in the game one of the second match
of the new inches classic goes to hikaru
who is one step closer to tying the
match and forcing tiebreak so already uh
we're up to
an incredible start and we'll see if
hikaru can take it all the way
so really really an impressive game i
mean this is uh
if we if we really wanted to analyze all
of the things that happened here we
would need like an hour long video but
uh you know i i hope i at least
you know try to do i mean i have tried i
don't know if i uh
was successful in showing what uh what a
crazy game this was
so i hope you guys enjoyed that uh i
would like to thank uh
colin lancaster dustin lackey rob toy uh
tom darrell
and ricardo ross for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the new chess
classic
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day